Merhaba değerli dostum mes kemi kimya
kanalına Hoş geldin birinci temaya devam
ediyoruz Nerede kalmıştık atom modelleri
ve atomun yapısında kalmıştık şu ana
kadar neler gördük şöyle bir
hatırlayalım istersen dedik ki günlük
hayatta kimya yani kimya hayattır
kısmından bahsetmiştik işte günlük
hayatta kimya dedik Orada alüminyum
folyonun kaplamada yani yemeği
kapladığımız nelere sebep olduğundan
bahsettik marinasyon ne yapıyordu işte
asitli bir şeylerle kaplarsak ne
oluyordu bunlardan bahsettik Hatırlarsan
pH olayından bahsettik su ilavesiyle pH
nasıl değişir bunların detaylarından
bahsettik sonra neden bahsettik
laboratuvar güvenlik kuralları ve
laboratuvar aletleri dedik ondan sonra
da bitirmiştik bu dersimizde atom
modellerinden bahsedeceğim bu atom
modelleri nasıl ortaya çıkmış nasıl bir
gelişim olmuş bundan bahsedeceğim
sonrasında Orbital kavramı yörünge
kavramı bunların farklarından
bahsedeceğiz oraya kadar gelip ne yapmış
olacağız dersimize ara vereceğiz dostum
Ha bu arada konuyla ilgili pdf'i de zeda
comom danan ne yapabilirsin bulabilirsin
tüm Z takımı yanında okula destek olmak
için hazır yeni müfredat var Ne yapman
gerek gerektiğini Oraya girip her şeyi
öğrenebilirsin dostum Bu arada diğer
hocalarımı ve beni de takip etmeyi
unutmazsan çok mutlu olurum o zaman hadi
vakit kaybetmiyoruz hazırsan başlayalım
geçmişten günümüze bir sürü insan atomla
ilgili bazı ifadeler kullanmıştır mesela
Bunlardan birisi democritus Dur
democritus bir şeyler söylüyordu Maddeyi
oluşturan en küçük yapı biriminin atom
olduğunu atomus olduğunu söylüyor Daha
doğrusu tüm maddeler atom denilen
parçacıklardan oluşur diyor Bunu da
tabii biraz felsefi yaklaşım olarak
söylüyor şöyle düşün işte diyor ki Bir
maddeyi ben ikiye böldüm bir daha böldüm
böldüm böldüm böldüm böldüm illaki diyor
bölünemeyen bir parçacık çıkacaktır
diyor İşte buna atomus diyor yani
maddeler atomlardan oluşur ifadesini
felsefi olarak ilk olarak kim söylüyor
democritus Söylüyor dostum böyle
söylerken zorlandım Peki başka kimin
çalışması vardı Mesela Cabir bin Hayyan
da bunu söylüyordu yani maddeler
zerrelerden oluşmuştur gibi bir ifade
kullanıyordu Hatta onun şöyle de bir
ifadesi var diye hatırlıyorum Onu da
inceleyebilirsin ben öyle bir aklımda
kalmış da söyleyeyim diyor ki işte
maddeler zerrelerden oluşmuştur diyor bu
zerreyi diyor Eğer parçalarsak diyor
muazzam bir enerji açığa çıkar diyor Bak
bu da Felsefi bir yaklaşım yani Deneysel
bir yaklaşım değil tabii ki yani gidip
de atomu parçalamış ama atomun
parçalanması sonucunda büyük bir enerji
açığa çıkacağından bahsetmiş böyle
basitçe yani bunu teorik olarak söylemiş
yani böyle bir şey olabilir şeklinde bir
ifade kullanmış Tabii bu ne Tabii ki
felsefi yaklaşım atomla ilgili ilk
kavram neydi milattan önce 400'lü
yıllarda democritus tarafından
söyleniyor diyor ki işte atomlar ve boş
uzay dan başka var olan hiçbir şey
yoktur diyor geri kalan her şey görüştür
diyor bak Felsefi bir yaklaşım İşte bu
felsefeci böyle güzel bir ifade
kullanmış atomdan ilk bahseden kişi
olarak tarihe geçiyor dostum ve ne diyor
işte her şeyin atomlardan ve boşluktan
oluştuğunu öne sürmüş diyor ki
bölünemeyen en küçük Par çocuk bu da
Yunancada neydi işte atomus şeklinde
ifade ediliyordu Yani ilk isim o şekilde
gelmiş atom yani ne demekmiş bölünemeyen
parçacık demekmiş hoş Şu anda bayağı bir
değişti de atomun parçalanabilen ortaya
çıkarıldı da Sonuçta bu o zamanki şeye
göre açıklamaya göre atom böyle bir
şeydi dostum E tabii bu ifadeyi
kullanınca olabilir mi diğerlerinde
aklına şüpheyi düşürdü mü düşürdü bak
felsefi olarak bir şey kullanınca diğer
insanlar da düşünmeye başladı Lan evet
lan Böyle bir şey olabilir mi acaba
deyip araştırmaya başladılar ve
sonrasında bilimsel olarak atomdan ilk
bahseden kişi kim John Dalton dostum
Dalton bu şeydeki değil tabii Redkit ve
daltonlardaki Dalton dan bahsetmiyoruz
John Dalton da bilimsel olarak bahs eden
ilk kişidir ki zaten buna atom modeli
diyoruz model ne demek acaba model
Aslında şöyle bir şeydir Böyle
insanların anlayabileceği şekle getirmek
Yani bir model oluşturuyor Daha doğrusu
nasıl söyleyeyim bir fikir ortaya atıyor
şöyle şöyle olması lazım diye bir fikir
ortaya atıyor E bunu insanların
anlayabileceği görsel hale dönüştürmesi
lazım İşte buna da model Diyoruz ki
zaten burada da gösteriyor bak teori
dediğimiz olay üç kısımdan oluşuyor
diyor ki teori veya kuram bir konu olay
veya olgu hakkında genel sistemli bir
bir açıklamadır ya şöyle şöyle olması
lazım maddeler atomlardan oluşur gibi
bir ifade kullanıyor Bak bunu söylüyor
bu böyle bir teori ortaya atıyor sonra
da bununla ilgili çalışmalar yapıyor
teori belirli bir konuyu anlamak
açıklamak öngörülerde bulunmak amacıyla
geliştirilen kapsamlı genel geçer bir
çerçevedir böyle bir şey olabilir diye
ne yapıyor ortaya atıyor sonra
araştırmalar başlıyor Tabii ki Peki
teori niye üretiliyor teori şundan
dolayı üretiliyor Bilimsel araştırmalar
sonucunda elde edilen bilgileri ve
bunların nedenlerini ve bu bilgiler
arasındaki ilişkiyi kurmak için açık
lamak için üretiliyor yani böyle bir şey
ortaya atıyor Ondan sonra millet
başlıyor yani Delinin birisinin kuyuya
taş atması gerekiyor işte bu taşı atan
kişi oluyor bu fikri söyleyen kişi o
fikir de ne oluyor işte teori oluyor
dostum model de işte ne gerçek nesne
olgu ve olay ve yasaları açıklamak için
üretilmiş teorileri temsil etmek için
yapılan nelerdir işte şekiller başka
semboller görseller bu şekilde
söyleyebiliriz mesela Dalton atom modeli
birazdan açıklayacağım diyor ki atom içi
dolu küredir Aha dalton'un atom modeli
bu Bak ne yaptık şekillendirdim gördün
mü içi dolu bir küre yaptım mesela ha
Bak burada da gösteriyor şöyle
yaklaşalım da şöyle yaklaşalım değil mi
Dalton burada Çünkü bak Dalton abimiz
diyor ki Maddenin en küçük yapı taşı
atomdur diyor maddeler atomlardan oluşur
atomlar çok küçük bölünemez
taneciklerdir diyor atom Bir de ne
ifadesi kullanıyor içi dolu Berk küredir
diyor böyle sağlam sert içi dolu küredir
diyor yani atomu ne diye ifade ediyor
çok küçük misketçik gibi düşünebilirsin
Başka ne söylüyor bir elementin tüm
atomlara özdeştir diyor yani Demir
elementi dediğimde Hepsi birbirinin
aynısı olan atomlardan oluşur diyor
Demir elementi He bir şeyler var onu
söyleyeceğim Başka ne söylüyor her
elementin kendine özgü atomu vardır yani
her elementin atomu birbirinden
farklıdır o zamana kadar atom dediğimi
tüm maddeler Aynı şeyden oluşuyor diye
düşünüyorlardı ama Oysa ki her elementin
atomunun birbirinden farklı olduğunu
söylüyor Peki bu adamın söylediklerinde
Hiç mi hata yok tabii ki var işte O da
burada hataları ve eksiklikleri atom içi
dolu küre değildir büyük kısmı boşluktan
oluşur Bu birinci hatası Ama tabii oir
ne bilmiyor Yani daha yeni oluşturmuş
bir şey zaten ilk olarak söylediğinden
dolayı sonrakiler ne yapıyor Onun
teorisini çürütmek için çalışma yapıyor
Böylelikle Aslında o kuyuya taşı attığı
için ne yapmış oluyor Diğerlerini de
geliştirmiş oluyor Başka atomlar
fiziksel ve kimyasal olayla parçalanamaz
doğru ama radyoaktif olay dediğimiz
çekirdek reaksiyonları var ki bununla
parçalanabilir yani Ne oldu atom
parçalanabilir bir şeymiş değil mi Bunu
da anlamış olduk Bu da eksikliği başka
bir elementin tüm atomları birbirinin
aynısı değildir Aynı büyüklükte değildir
farklı büyüklüktedir kütle numaraları
nötron sayıları farklı olduğu için
farklı büyüklükte olanları da vardır
Buna izotop atomlar şeklinde bir ifade
kullanıyoruz şu an söylemiyoruz sadece
Bak ne diyor aynı elemente ait nötron
sayıları farklı atomlar da vardır diyor
yani bir elementin tüm atomları Aynı
büyüklükte Özdeş değildir farklılıklar
vardır hafif biraz büyük biraz küçük
gibi yani şöyle düşün ikizler var
birbirinin tamamen aynısı bazen
diyemiyoruz neden biri kilolu oluyor
biri daha zayıf oluyor değil mi böyle
bir durum olabiliyor aynı onun gibi
düşünebilirsin dostum sonra kim geliyor
Dalton dan sonra Thomson geliyor Thomson
bu atom modelini diyor ki araştırayım La
diyor yani Dalton böyle bir şey söyledi
de diyor Ben de bir bakayım diyor o
zamanlar katot ışını tüpü diye bir şey
geliştiriliyor crooks diye bir adam
buluyor katot ışını tüpünü
geliştirdikten sonra bununla çalışmalar
yaparken Şunu fark ediyor hat da şöyle
Şuraya da çizmek istiyorum Bak şöyle bir
şekil var böyle bir şekli var eski Neye
benziyor biliyor musun tüplü
televizyonlara benziyor diyor ki Işın
çık çıktığında şöyle bir şey yapıyor
Hatta L Niye çizmiyor ki yani böyle şey
yapıyorum Hah şöyle şu şekilde bir yapı
önünde böyle e renkleri belli eden böyle
ışımaları belli eden bir yapı var Şuraya
bir tane şey koyuyor yüksek voltajlı bir
yapı yerleştiriyor buraya yüksek enerji
verdiğinde bir Işın çıktığını fark
ediyor çıkan ışına elektriksel alan
uyguluyor elektriksel ve manyetik alan
elektriksel alan uyguladığında artı ve
eksiler uyguluyor Şunu fark ediyor çıkan
ışığın artıya doğru saptığını fark
ediyor sonra element değiştiriyor yani
şuraya koyduğu metali değiştiriyor
farklı metallerle yaptığında aynı ışık
çıkıyor ve çıkan Işık hep nereye sapıyor
artıya sapıyor artıya saptığını göre
eksi yüklüdür diyor bak Birinci buluş
çok güzel o zaman atomda diyor eksi
yükler bulunur diyor Aha bak çok önemli
bir buluş yaptı bu adam atomda negatif
yüklü parçacıklar vardır diyor ki buna
Daha sonra stoney diye bir adam da
elektron ismini veriyor ama sonuçta
bulan kişi kim elektronu keşfeden kişi
Böylelikle kim olmuş oldu atom modeli
üzerinden söylüyorum tabii Thomson olmuş
oldu peki atom nötrdür diyor toplamda
nötr Ee eksi yük varsa diyor o zaman
atomda pozitif bir yapı da olması lazım
diyor ve işte açıklama burada geliyor
diyor ki atom dışı Pozitif yüklü bir
küredir diyor negatif yüklü tanecikler
kek içerisindeki üzümlerin keke böyle
homojen dağılması gibi dağılmıştır diyor
yani üzümlü kek modeli diyoruz buna işte
bir şey var orada kek pozitif küre
içerisindeki üzümler ise negatif
parçacıklar yani elektronlar toplamı da
nötrdür diyor Başka atomda işte artı ve
eksi yük sayısı eşittir yani nötrdür ve
atomun kütlesini bu pozitif yüklü küre
oluşturmaktadır şeklinde bir ifade
kullanıyor peki bunun eksiklikleri yok
mu Tabii ki var şimdi bu adam hala şeyi
söylenmedi atomun Büyük bir kısmı
boşluktur yok ve bu boşlukta elektronlar
yani negatif parçacıklar bulunmaktadır
yani böyle homojen dağılma gibi bir
durum söz konusu değil başka pozitif
yüklü taneciklerle ilgili diyor ki atom
pozitif bir küredir hayır diyor
gerçeğinde şöyle bir şey var o pozitif
yüklü tanecikler çok küçük bir yerde
toplanmış oluyor e o yüzden bu hatalı e
atomun kütlesinin pozitif yüklü
taneciklerden oluştuğunu söylüyor ya Bu
da eksiklik Çünkü orada yüksüz olan
nötronlar da var yani Proton ve nötron
kütleyi belirlemek Evet elektronun
kütlesi o kadar küçük ki onu yok
sayabiliriz Hatta şöyle söyleyeyim bir
protonun kütlesinin
1836 bir'i kadar diyebilirim o kadar
küçük o yüzden elektronun kütlesi yok
gibi kabul edebiliriz Daha sonra yine
söyleyeceğim bunu zaten Proton nötron ve
elektronun kütlesi ile ilgili yorumlar
yapacağız Sonra Rutherford geliyor Buna
gezegen modeli diyoruz diyor ki atomun
bir çekirdeği vardır diyor yani atomda
artı yükler çok küçük bir hacimde
toplanmıştır diyor Hatta bunu da sana
şöyle anlatayım dostum deney yapıyor
deney ince altın levha üzerine Alfa
ışınları yolluyor Alfa ışınları artı
yüklü bir atom yani atomun artı yüklü
hali helyum atomunun bunu yolladığında
atomun içinden geçtiğini fark ediyor
Normalde amacı Thomson atom modelini
kanıtlamak fakat fark ettiği şey şu
oluyor ışınlar hop delip geçiyor
Eyvallah diyor ki A tamam hepsinin
arkada okunması lazım la bir bakıyor
sağa sola saçılmalı var la diyor artı
yüklü bir şeyin diyor yön değiştirmesine
sebep olacak ancak ve ancak yoğun bir
artı yük olması lazım diyor la bu atom
başka bir atomun içinden geçiyorsa
atomun Büyük bir kısmı boşluktur diyor
birinci ifade çok önemli ikinci ifade
artı yükler diyor Çok küçük bir hacimde
toplanması lazım ki diyor çünkü sapan
kısım çok az 20.000'e biri sapıyor Veya
geriye sapıyor Demek ki diyor bu artı
yüklü tanecikler çok küçük bir yerde
toplanmış ki zor denk geliyor atomda
artı yükler çok küçük bir yerde
toplanmıştır diyerek atomun
çekirdeğinden bahsediyor atom çekirdeği
kavramını ilk kullanan adam bu şu anda
devam edelim işte başka Ne söylüyordu ve
eksi yükler diyor Bunun çevresinde
rastgele Dolanır şeklinde yani o gezegen
modeli gibi söylüyor işte diyor ki güneş
sistemine benzetiyor kısmen atomda
pozitif yükün çekirdekte olduğunu
söylüyor yani atom çekirdeği kavramını
söylüyor artı yüklerin kütlesi atom
kütlesinin neredeyse yarısıdır diyor
şöyle bir ifade kullanıyor atom
kütlesini çekirdek belirler diyor
elektronların kütlesi yok denecek kadar
az ama diyor çekirdeğin de yaklaşık
yarısı diyor
protonda şimdi o zaman Ne oldu atomun
çekirdeği var yarısında Proton var diğer
yarısında ne var yüksüz bir şey olması
lazım ama açıklayamıyor y böyle bir
şeyin varlığından bahsediyor ama
açıklayamıyor işte elektronlar çekirdek
çevresinde işte belirli uzaklıkta
rastgele ne yapar döner şeklinde bir
ifade kullanıyor şimdi bu adamın
eksikliklerinden bahsedersek de şöyle
bir durum söz konusu bu elektronlar
rastgele Dolanır diyor ya şunu
soruyorlar adama diyorlar ki ya bu
şeyler e eksi yüklü parçacıklar yani
elektronlar çekirdek çekiyorsa bunu
dönüp dönüp Çat diye çekirdeğe niye
düşmüyor E bunu açıklayamıyor Çünkü
modeli eksik bu noktada Bir de neyi
açıklayamıyor işte nötronun varlığından
bahsedeyim bir elektronların hareketini
açıklayamıyor iki nötronun varlığından
bahsetmiyor Yani bu adamın iki tane
eksiği bu şekilde söylenebilir sonra
geliyor Bor atom modeli yani Bor atom
modeli de aslında belki Rutherford atom
modeli ile ilgili çalışma yapıyor o
sırada ortaya çıkıyor bak Bir önceki
teoriyi çalışıyorlar yeni bir şey
keşfediyorlar her seferinde bak ne
yapıyor bu yörüngeli model olarak
bildiğimiz modeli ORT çıkıyor yani
elektronların çekirdek çevresinde
belirli enerji seviyeli yörüngelerde
döndüğünü söylüyor bak önemli bir
ifadedir başka ne var elektronlar Heh
Çekirdekten belirli uzaklıkta
yörüngelerde bulunur temel haldeki atom
Kararlıdır Işın yaymaz diyor ama
uyarılmış halde Yani enerji almış atom
Işın yayar gibi bir ifade kullanıyor ve
Çekirdekten uzaklaştıkça katmanların
enerjisi artar diyor Bunu da Deneylerle
ispatlıyor dostum yani bayağı bir deney
yapıyor Onunla beraber çalışma yapan bir
bilim insanı da bunun eksikliğini ortaya
çıkarıyor ondan da bahsederiz hıh
eksiklikleri hataları bir kere
elektronun hareketini açıklayamıyor tam
Yani şöyle katman modelinden bahsediyor
enerji seviyesinden bahsediyor ama
elektronun yeri sanki belirlenebilir
gibi bir anlam ortaya çıkıyor dairesel
yörüngelerde döner diyor ama Oysa ki
elektronun yeri tam olarak belirlenemez
Bundan dolayı bu bir eksikliktir tek
elektronlu da çok güzel açıklayabilir
ama çok elektronlarda bunu açıklayamıyor
dostum İşte o çok elektronlarda
açıklayamıyor elektronun yeriyle ilgili
sıkıntı lar var ya onu da Heisenberg
diye bir adam geliyor ve bir sürü kişi
var tabii ki Heisenberg Schrödinger
Einstein bir sürü kişi var Max plank
falan bunların hepsinin ortak
çalışmaları sonucunda bir atom modeli
ortaya çıkıyor o da Bulut modeli ya da
kuantum modeli şeklinde ifade ediliyor
ya da işte modern atom modeli şeklinde
ifade ediliyor kuantum modelinde şöyle
bir şey vardır elektronun yeri ve hızı
aynı anda hassasiyetle belirlenemez
diyor bunu Heisenberg buluyor Heisenberg
de bu Breaking btek inden bahsetmiyorum
Tabii ki Heisenberg şö öyle bir ifade
kullanıyor diyor ki elektronun hızı çok
büyük kütlesi çok küçük olduğu için yeri
tam olarak belirlenemez yani yerini
belirlemeye kalksak bu sefer diyor
hızını belirleyemez Çünkü değişir Eğer
diyor hızını belirlemeye kalkarsak diyor
yeri değişir diyor yani tam olarak
belirlenemez diyor bu diyor Şu anki
bilimsel eksiklikten kaynaklanmıyor
diyor fiziğin doğasıyla alakalı bir
durumdur diyor elektronun yeri
belirlenemez gibi bir ifade kullanıyor
Daha sonra da işte he burada Peki
elektronun yeri belirlenemiyorsa ne
yapacağız şuralarda bir yerde
diyebilirsin elektron şuralarda bir yer
İşte buna Bulut modeli ya da Orbital
ifadesini kullanıyoruz elektron
buralarda bir yerde bulunma olasılığının
en yüksek olduğu yerlere Orbital
ifadesini kullanıyoruz bunu da irwin
Schrödinger dediğimiz bir adam buluyor
çeşitli böyle bir deneyler yapıyor pis
kare formülü falan var işte onun
üzerinden çalışma yapıyor ve bu çalışma
sonucunda da elektronun yeriyle alakalı
belli şeyler keşfediyor Dostum şimdi
bakalım bu modellerle ilgili nasıl
sorular var bakalım Diyor ki John Dalton
ortaya koyduğu atom modelindeki
görüşlerinden Hang hangileri günümüzde
geçerlidir diyor bu adamın geçerli olan
şeyi maddeler atomlardan oluşmuştur
ifadesi olabilir evet maddeler
atomlardan oluşmuştur birincisi Evet
günümüzde hala geçerli atom içi dolu
küredir Hayır atomda büyük boşluklar
vardır Bunun yanlış olduğu ispatlandı
diyor ki atomlar en küçük taneciklerdir
Hayır Proton nötron elektron alt
parçacıklar var o yüzden bu da gitti
diyor ki her elementin atomları
birbirinden farklıdır Evet tüm
elementlerin atomları birbirinden
farklıdır Bunu söylemişti Doğrudur hala
da geçerlidir bu 1 ve 4 günümüzde
geçerli nerede B seçeneğinde Burada ne
diyor bak Yukarıdaki tepkime Dalton atom
teorisindeki varsayımlarından
varsayımlardan hangileriyle uyumlu
değildir diyor şimdi Dalton atom modeli
ne diyordu atom içi dolu küredir diyordu
atom parçalanamaz diyordu başka bir
elementin bütün atomları aynı
büyüklüktedir diyordu bu ifadeleri
kullanıyordu değil mi bakalım bir
elementin tüm atomları özdeştir Bak
bunun neyini uyumlu olmadığını tespit
ettik Neden Çünkü Bak bu da karbon Bu da
karbon ama birinin kütle numarası 14
birin iki 13 haliyle bunların büyüklük
ne olacaktır farklı olacaktır bu uyumlu
değil Bunu alabiliriz başka ne var diyor
ki atom bilinen en küçük taneciktir
Hayır Bak nötronu burada görüyorsun
değil mi buradaki denklemden daha küçük
bir tanecik olduğunu belirledik Yani bu
da uyumlu olmadığını göstermiş oluyor
atom parçalanamaz e atomun
parçalanabilir bak nötron içindeki
parçacıklar girip çıkabiliyor haliyle
atom parçalanabilir bir şeymiş Demek ki
bunu da anlamış oluyoruz yani atom
teorisindeki varsayımlar ile uyumlu
değildir Bu denklem o yüzden cevap Ne
oldu e seçeneği oldu buraya bakalım
diyor ki Thomson atom modelinde
sorularından hangilerine doğru cevap
alınamamıştır Hım bakalım atom kütlesini
hangi tanecikler oluşturur Thompson
diyor ki pozitif küre belirlemiştir
diyor e nötrondan bahsetmiyor Demek ki
Buna cevap alamamıştır güzel başka ne
var atom içerisindeki elektronların
konumu tespit edilebilir mi bu homojen
olarak dağılmıştır diyordu Oysaki
elektronun yeri tam olarak
belirlenemiyorsa
ne vardı elektron diyordu değil mi yani
daha küçük tanecikler olduğundan
bahsediyordu Bundan dolayı üçüncünün
cevabını almışızdır 1 ve 2nin alamamış
ZD cevap da o yüzden B seçeneğidir bu
sorumuza bakalım Diyor ki atomun yapısı
ile ilgili Yukarıdaki ifadelerden
hangileri Thomson atom modelinden
günümüze kadar kabul görmüştür günümüze
kadar kabul gören atomda negatif yüklü
tanecikler olduğudur Çünkü atom neydi
işte üzümlü keke benzemiyordu yani artı
eksi yükler homojen dağılmamıştır
haliyle bunlar değil diye ama geçerli
olan elektronun varlığı atomdaki negatif
yüklü tanecikler rastgele dağılmışlardır
Hayır günümüzde Bu geçerli değildir
elektronlar negatif yüklü taneciklerdir
Evet bunu belirlemişti doğru atom
pozitif yüklü içi dolu küre şeklindedir
Hayır günümüzde geçerli değil neydi atom
işte çekirdek çok küçük bir hacim İşte
bu neydi protonlar buradaydı yani atomun
tamamı böyle pozitif bir küre şeklinde
değildi bu da günümüzde geçerli değildir
kabul gören günümüzde hala geçerli olan
Yalnız ikidir o da nerede a seçeneği
bakalım Bu soruda ne diyor Diyor ki
Rutherford atom modelinin kendinden ne
öncekilerden farklı kendinden sonraki
atom modellerinin de desteklediği en
büyük keşfi hangisidir bak çok böyle
değişik bir ifade kullanmış kendinden
öncekilerden farklı bir şey söyleyecek
ve kendinden sonrakilerde bu ifadeyi
destekleyecek neydi Rutherford neler
söylemişti atom büyük bir yani atom
Büyük bir kısmı boşluktur atom atom ne
demek L atomun Büyük bir kısmı boşluktur
He Bunu söylemişti Başka ne s demişti
atomda artı yükler çok küçük bir hacimde
toplanmıştır yani atom çekirdeğinden
bahsetmişti Bu ikisi hala geçerli ama
elektronun hareketi ile ilgili veya
nötrondan bahsetmemesi ile ilgili
durumlar yani yüksüz tanecik ama nötron
yok değil mi bunlar hala yani
söyleyememiş günümüzden sonrakiler için
onlar günümüzden sonra keşfedilmişti o
yüzden onlar yok Bakalım şimdi nötron
Hayır bunu açıklamamış tı Proton değil
atom çekirdeği tam olarak söylediği
şeydi ve günümüzde hala geçerliydi
sonrakilerde destekliyordu o yüzden
cevap C seçeneğidir bu arada da Proton
mesela goldstein diye biri tarafından
keşfedilmişti kanal ışınları deneyiyle
galiba keşfedilmişti geldik 6'ya diyor
ki Rutherford atom modeli Thomson atom
modelindeki varsayımlardan hangilerinin
yanlışlığını ortaya koymuştur Rutherford
geldiğinde thompson'dan bulmuştu bakalım
Rutherford atomun Büyük bir kısmı
boşluktur demişti e atom pozitif bir
küre dememişti Yani bunun yanlışlığını
ispat etti başka atomdan daha küçük
tanecikler vardır İkisi de söylüyor
aslında sonuçta elektronun varlığını
söylüyordu Thomson o O yüzden bu
değildir atomda pozitif ve negatif yük
sayısı eşittir hala geçerlidir ve
yanlışlığı değil İkisi de söylüyor bunu
Çünkü atom nötrdür Proton ve nötron
sayısı eşittir diyordu O yüzden bu da
değil cevap Yalnız bir a seçeneği olmalı
bu sorumuza bakalım Diyor ki Rutherford
atom modelindeki varsayımlardan
hareketle sonuçlarından hangilerine
Ulaşmak mümkündür diyor ki pozitif
yüklerin kütlesi atom kütlesine eşittir
Hayır böyle söylemiyordu diyordu ki atom
kütlesinin yaklaşık yarısı
protondb şluk yapıdadır Evet bunu
söylüyordu pozitif atom içindeki
elektronlar hareket halindedir Evet ne
oluyordu çekirdek çevresinde hareket
halinde dönüyorlardı bunu söylüyordu O
zaman cevap 2 ve 3 D seçeneği olacaktır
Bak bu da değişik bir soru diyor ki
aşağıdaki sorularla ilgili
düşüncelerinizi renkli kutucuklara
yazınız bak böyle etkinlik gibi olmuş
diyor ki İlk çağlardan beri maddelerin
oluşturduğuna inanılan ve bölünemez
olduğu düşünüldüğü için bu anlamda
isimlendirilen bölünemeyen tanecik Neydi
bu atom ustu değil mi atom ifadesi
olacaktır burası Bak birincisinden aldık
bilgiyi ikinciye geldik diyor ki bu
kavramın ilk olarak düşünülmesine ve
geliştirilmesinde etkili olan şey
deneysel Temelli çalışmalar mıdır
değilse nedir deneysel temel yoktu ilk
başta böyle fikir olarak söylüyordu yani
felsefi yaklaşım olacaktır burada
yaklaşım böyle bir şey söyleyebiliriz o
felsefi olarak söylüyorlar sonra
gelişiyor bu durum bilgileri aldık devam
ediyoruz atomun yapısındaki
taneciklerden ilk keşfedilen taneciğin
hangi özelliği onun ilk olarak
keşfedilmeseydi böyle bir deney
yapıyordu böyle artıya doğru sapıyor
yani Yüklü olması ile alakalı bir durum
söz konusu eksi yüklüydü bunu keşfediyor
e atom nötr olduğuna göre eksi yüklü bir
şey varsa demek ki artı yüklü bir yapıda
olması gerekir diyordu yani yüklü olması
diyebiliriz yüklü olması burada bak
atomun yapısındaki taneciklerden ilk
keşfedilen yani elektrondan bahsediyoruz
taneciğin
keşfedilmeseydi olması etkindir yani
eksi yük dedim mi elektron dedim mi
aklımıza ne geliyor elektrik geliyor
değil mi yani elektrik kavramının
gelişmiş olması gerekiyor Elektrik
bulunduktan sonra zaten bunlar
geliştirilebilir Başka ne var sonuncuya
bakalım Diyor ki Atomun temel
taneciklerinden son keşfedilen tanecik
en son keşfedilen nötrondan da
söyleyeyim önce ne yaptık işte elektronu
bulduk sonra Rutherford deneyiyle işte
çekirdek kavramı protonlar falan filan
yani o döneme işte işte neyi buluyorlar
Proton da keşfediliyor nötron
bahsedemeyiz de nötronu aklımıza
getireceğiz diyor ki Atomun temel
taneciklerinden son keşfedilen taneciğin
ilk keşfedilen taneciğe göre hangi
özelliğinin farklı olması onun keşfinde
etkili olmuş olabilir E bu da tabii ki
kütlesinin olmasıdır yani yüksüz olması
tam olarak söyleyemiyoruz keşf
edilmesinde bunun kütlesinin olması
önemli Çünkü bak Bak şöyle yapıyor
Rutherford deneyi yapıyordu ne yapıyor
işte diyor ki atom kütlesinin yaklaşık
yarısı
protonda sahip başka bir tanecik var
Eğer şöyle olsaydı yani yüksüz
anlayamazdı ki artı var Eksi var ıır
zaten tamam bitti birbirini nötrle
herhangi bir ıır yüklü tanecikten
bahsedemezsin ki ama Düşünsene atom
kütlesinden bahsediyorsun yarısı Proton
Demek ki yarısı da başka bir şey Ama
yükü olmaması lazım sonradan onu
söylüyorsun işte yani kütlesinin olması
önemli orada buraya da o zaman Yazalım
kütlesinin
olması etkilidir diyebiliriz şimdi o
zaman geldik nereye bu atom modelinden
bahsettik işte atom modellerini
geliştirdik geliştirdik geldik o zaman
atomdaki temel taneciklerden
bahsedebiliriz artık ne vardı Proton
vardı nötron vardı elektron vardı işte
burada da temel tanecikler derken Atomun
temel tanecikleri derken bundan
bahsedeceğiz nelerden bahsediyor işte
bir elementin tüm özelliklerini taşıyan
en küçük yapı birimine atom ifadesini
kullanıyoruz yani Demir dediğimizde
orada Demir atomları vardır onun
özelliğini taşıyan en küçük parçacık
değil mi Başka atomun yapısında atomu
oluşturan daha küçük tanecikler bulunur
ki Biz bunlara atom altı tanecikler
diyoruz Proton nötron elektron Bunlar
temel tanecikler eyvallah Ama bunun altı
da var Bak burada da gösteriyoruz Tamam
Proton nötron elektron söyledik atomun
çapı yaklaşık 10 üzeri -8 cm çekirdeğin
çapı yaklaşık 10 üzeri -12 10 üzeri -13
cm böyle daha küçük bir yapı burada
Proton var nötron var elektron var
Eyvallah Bir de çekirdeğin içerisinde
tanecik vardı ya Proton ve nötron
bunların içerisinde de parçacıklar var
Yani bunlar da bir şeylerden oluşuyor
bunlara da kuarklar diyoruz bu işte
kuarkların Üç tanesi bir araya
geldiğinde protonu ve nötronu meydana
getiriyor İşte bu kuarkları bir arada
tutan da bir parçacık var Daha doğrusu
bir yapı var Bu da glon dediğimiz bir
parçacık ya bilmek zorunda değilsin
Sadece şunun için söylüyorum bunu atom
altı parçacıklar vardır ki bunlar daha
bir şey değil mezonlar şunlar bunlar
daha bir sürü parçacık var burada İşte
basit olarak ifade ediyor atomun
çekirdeği işte verilmiş oradan protonun
veya nötronun Neyse artık o Yapı
gösteriliyor kuarklardan oluştuğunu
söylüyor ve bu kuarkların birleşmesini
sağlayan da glon dediğimiz bir yapıdan
bahsediyor işte bunların hepsi atom altı
parçacıklar şeklinde söylüyoruz dostum
Hatta Bak burada ne diyor Görüyor musun
bak 300'ün üzerinde atom altı parçacık
bulunmasına rağmen biz sadece Proton
nötron ve elektronla uğraşıyoruz o
konuda Kafan rahat olsun hocam quark
dedin gluon dedin Ne oluyor Bir şaşırdım
Korkma korkma Proton nötron elektron
başka işimiz yok Bak atomda iki Yapı
vardı anladığımız bu çekirdek vardı bir
de yörüngeler daha doğrusu orbitaller
vardı elektron bulutu vardı e çekirdekte
ne vardı Proton ve nötron vardı E bu
orbitallerde ne vardı elektronlar Vardı
E bunların özelliklerinden bahsedeceğim
Ama önce şunu söyleyeyim Bu keşfedilme
sırası üzerinden bak atom altı
parçacıkların keşfedilme sırası önce
katot ışınları deneyi ve Faraday
deneyleriyle o elektronun varlığından
bahsediliyor sonra goldstein pozitif
ışınları kanal ışınları deneyiyle işte
onu keşfetmiş oluyor sonra ne yapıyor
Thomson neyi bulmuş oluyor eksi yüklü
parçacık üzerinden işte elektronu
keşfetmiş oluyor elektronun keşfinden
sonra devam ediyoruz ne oluyor atomda
pozitif yüklü yapıdan dolayı Proton da
keşfedilmiş oluyor sonra geliyoruz işte
yüksüz tanecik diyor Rutherford sonra
hemen chadwick atlıyor hemen o yormuş ya
aha bir tanecik var Ben bunu bulayım da
bari tarihe geçeyim diyor Herhalde 1913
1932 kadar artık bir süreç oluyor
1932'de de ne yapıyor işte chadwick
nötronu keş keş ediyor dostum o zaman
bak protonun özellikleri Proton P ile
gösterilir p + ya da p genellikle P ile
göstereceğiz çekirdekte bulunur yükü +
1,62 x 10 üzeri -19 Klon dediğimiz bir
değer ya Önemli değil biz buna + 1
diyoruz bağıl kütle olarak + 1 ifadesini
kullanıyoruz kütlesi ise
1,67 x 10 üzeri -24 gram bak çok küçük
bir şey zaten ama bu şeyle Uğraşılmaz
bağıl bir kütle vermem lazım Biz bunu
yaklaşık 1 diyoruz ya da işte 1,0 bilmem
ne Neyse şu küsürat var ya bu küsür at
dikkat etmeni istiyorum çünkü protonla
nötronun kütlesi yaklaşık olarak aynı
diyoruz aynı değil birebir aynı değil
yaklaşık olarak aynı Onu da nötrona
göstereyim bak nötron ne ile
gösteriliyor ya da n üzeri 0'la
çekirdekte bulunuyor yükü 0 kütlesi
1,67 x 10 üzeri -24 bak 673 675 çok az
büyük çok az o da
1,00 86 bir şey işte yani Çok az büyük
derken bunu kastediyorum elektrona e ile
gösteriliyor ya da e üzeri eksi ile
gösteriliyor orbitallerde bulunuyor O
katmanlarda bulunuyordu yükü - 1,62 x 10
üzeri -19 Bak gördün mü şu değerleri Bak
burada da var burada da var yani İkisi
birbirine eşit olmak zorunda eşit sayıda
olduğunda eksi artı birbirini götürecek
ne olacak sıfırlanmış olacak ha buna da
-1 yüklü diyoruz kütlesi Bak görüyor
musun
9,19 Aa büyük mü acaba Hayır bak 10 üzer
-28 o 10 üzeri -24 bu 10 üzeri -28 ciddi
bir fark var burada zaten şöyle
söyleyeyim işte yaklaşık olarak bir
elektronun kütlesi protonun kütlesinin
1836 bir'i gibi bir şey çıkıyor E
kütlesi O yüzden yaklaşık 0 kabul
ediliyor diyoruz haah ekrandan çıkmasın
şimdi buraya bakalım Diyor ki atom altı
tanecikler ile ilgili yukarıdakilerden
hangileri yanlıştır Hım tüm atomlarda
elektron bulunur H atoms nötrdür nötr se
proton sayısı kadar elektron olmak
zorunda Proton olmak zorundaysa elektron
da olmak zorunda atom nötr ifadesidir
Bunu sakın unutma iyonlarda elektron
bulunmayabilir ama atomda bulunmak
zorundadır Proton ve elektron kesin
bulunmak zorunda nötron olmayabilir
hidrojenden bahsediyorum ama Onun
dışındaki tüm atomlarda nötron da
bulunmakta Hani nötron kesin değil ama
Proton elektron atoms nötr se kesin
vardır O yüzden birincisi Doğrudur diyor
ki nötron çekirdekte yer alır doğru
olduğunda da çekirdekte yer alır
kesinlikle bu da doğru bir ifadedir
kütlesi en büyük olan protonda Hayır çok
az nötron büyüktü değil mi kütleleri
nötron büyük Proton büyük Bu da
elektrondan büyük şeklinde Çift çizgi
hani çok büyük anlamında söylüyorum
yanlışı bulduk zaten cevap yalnız 3 B
seçeneği Burada da diyor ki atom
çekirdeğinde yer alan tanecikler ile
ilgili ifadelerinden hangileri doğrudur
bağıl kütleleri birbirine çok yakındır
Evet atom çekirdeğinde tanecikler Proton
ve nötrondan ve nötron Evet kütleleri
birbirine çok yakındı başka yükleri
zıttır Ya olur mu Proton artı yüklü
bununki sıfır zıt falan değil o yüzden
ne oldu yanlış oldu enerji alarak
orbitallere çıkabilir Yok daha neler
yani elektron var orbitallerde protonun
ne işi var orada yani Proton ve nötron
çekirdekte yeralır orbitallere geçemez
dostum o yüzden bu ifade yanlıştır Biz
doğruları aradığımız için cevabımız
yalnız bir a seçeneğidir şimdi buna
bakalım Diyor ki atomun yapısındaki
Proton ile ilgili Yukarıdaki ifadelerden
hangileri doğrudur Hım pozitif yüklüdür
Evet Proton pozitif yüklüydü kütlesi
1,67 x 10 üzeri -24 gramdır ya bilgi
sorusu oldu için Evet bu doğru bir ifade
75 olan nötronu 73 olan neydi protonda
diyor ki tüm atomlarda en az bir tane
Bulunur ya hidrojen ilki bir tane
bulunur helyum 2 işte lityum 3 Yani en
az bir tane olmak zorunda O yüzden doğru
bir ifadedir cevap da E seçeneğidir
şimdi geldik atomla ilgili bazı terimler
var atom numarası ifadesini duymuşsundur
kütle numarası falan nötr falan bunları
duymuşsundur ne demek onu söyleyelim
atom numarası atomun çekirdeğindeki
proton sayısı ına Söylediğimiz ifadedir
her atomda sayısı belirlidir ya ona
bakarak o atomda kaç tane Proton varsa
kimliğini belirleyebiliyor bak nötron
sayısı aynı olan tanecikler olabilir
elektron sayısı aynı olan iyon olarak
düşünürsek tanecikler olabilir ama
proton sayısı aynı olan farklı atomlar
mümkün değildir dostum Tamam mı Bundan
dolayı Proton sayısına bakarak Ne
yapabiliriz bir atomu tanıyabiliriz O
yüzden Proton sayısına atom numarası
ifadesi verilir aynı sayıda protona
sahip olan tüm atomlar aynı elemente
aittir ifadesini kullanıyoruz yani
karbon 6'ya 14 karbon 6'ya 13 ya Sonuçta
şunlar aynı mı Aynı proton sayısı
aynıysa aynı atomdur sadece kütle
numarası farklı olanlar olabiliyor bir
element atomunun çekirdeğindeki
protonların toplam sayısı işte atom
numarası olarak ifade ediliyordu buna
çekirdek yükü de deniliyor hocam İyon
yükü Hayır bak çekirdek yükü çekirdekte
Kimler var Proton var nötron var Hangisi
yüke sahip Proton yüke sahip değil mi o
yüzden de çekirdekteki yüke sahip
tanecik sayısı protonlar yani çekirdek
yükü olarak ifade edilmekte O zaman şunu
söyleyebiliriz atom numarası sığıyor mu
ekrana Evet atom numarası proton sayısı
çekirdek yükü bunlar aynı şey demektir
ve z harfiyle gösteriliyor atom
sembolünün şurasına yazılıyor işte şu
sol alt tarafına yazılıyor hidrojen
birmiş oksijen 8M miş brom da 35' mii
Mesela işte bunları söylüyoruz Yani bir
elementin sembolünü yazarsak şuraya atom
numarası yazılmış oluyor nötr atom
dediğimizde ise Proton sayısının
elektron sayısına eşit olduğu atomlardır
onu söylüyor işte nötr atom Aslında atom
dedim nötr aklımıza gelmeli ama sonuçta
Proton sayısının elektron sayısına eşit
olduğu duruma Biz nötr ifadesini
kullanıyoruz ki şu var bak Bu şey çok
önemlidir bir atomun neresine ne yazılır
bak şu üste kütle numarası yazılıyor
burada söylemiş şu ortaya sol ortaya
nötron sayısı yazılıyor Sol aşağıya
neydi atom numarası yazılıyor sağ
aşağıya elektron sayısı sağ üstte ise
varsa yükü yazılıyor şöyle bir
örneklendirme yapacağım dostum Bak x
yazdım şurası 9 nötr is burası da 9'dur
bir de iyon diye bir ifade vardır bak
iyon iyon dediğimiz Proton sayısının
Hatta şöyle yapayım Proton sayısının
elektron sayısına eşit olmadığı durumdur
eşit değilse iki ihtimal vardır ya
proton sayısı elektron sayısından
büyüktür ya da proton sayısı elektron
sayısından küçüktür e Proton büyükse
Proton artı yüklü elektron eksi yüklü
artıların sayısı eksiden fazlaysa bu
artı yüklü tanecik olacaktır e buradaysa
Proton elektrondan küçük olduğu için
eksi yüklü tanecik olacaktır işte artı
yüklü lere katyon ifadesini kullanacağız
daha sonra buna ise eksi yüklü lere ise
anyon ifadesini kullanacağız ve tabii
şöyle bir tane de örnek yapayım bak flor
dedim Burası 9 şurası da -1 bunu tekrar
söyleyeceğim Daha sonra -1 ise şuraya
elektron sayısını toplarsan sana Proton
sayısını verecek yani -1 + e = 9 İsa e =
10 çıktı mesela elektron sayısı 10m Muş
veya başka bir tane örnek yazayım
kalsiyum + 2'ye ne olsun olsun bu sefer
elektron sayısını vereyim 18 proton
sayısı nedir diye sordum yani buna Z
yazalım atom numarası nedir diye sordum
e yükle elektron sayısını topladığımızda
Ne oldu 20 çıktı proton sayısı 20m miş
diyebilirsin şimdi Bor atom modelini
ekstradan değerlendirmemiz lazım dostum
Bak Bor atom modeli önemlidir Bor bir
deney yapıyor şöyle elementleri
ısıttığımızda böyle Işık çıkarttığını
fark ediyor Hani ısınan bir metali
parladığını görmüşsündür değil mi İşte
parlaman sebebini araştırıyor ve
fosforlu saatlerdeki o fosforun akşam
vakti Işık saçtığını birazdan
göstereceğim onu yani bunları açıklamaya
çalışıyor Sonra da bir deney yapıyor
hidrojen elementini kullanıp hidrojen
gazını kullanıp bununla bir lamba
yapıyor bu Lambayı prizmadan
geçirdiğinde farklı çizgiler fark ediyor
farklı elementlerle farklı deneyler
yapıyor Fakat yaptığı deneylerde hep
elektron sayısı 1 olan tanecikleri
tercih ediyor tek elektronlar için
açıklayabilir ya o yüzden söylüyorum ama
bu deney sonucunda o prizmadan
geçirdiğinde farklı farklı çizgiler fark
ediyor ışıma olayları son ucunda ve
diyor ki la diyor barkod gibi diyor
birazdan göstereceğim onu barkod gibi
diyor her elementini diğerinden farklı
Ha o zaman her elementin bu ışıma
çizgileri farklıysa buna sebep olan bir
şey olması lazım diyor işte elektronun
hareketini buradan açıklamaya çalışıyor
ve diyor ki bak Dalton Thompson
Rutherford yaptıkları çalışmalarla atom
yapısına belli bir katkı sağlıyor Ne
yapıyor önemli gelişmeler K ediyorlar
ancak bilim insanları hiçbirisi atomdaki
elektronların davranışını açıklayamıyor
bunu Nils spor kendinden önceki bilim
insanlarından farklı olarak yapıyor
elektronun hareketi ile ilgili bir model
geliştiriyor ve diyor ki bak Demir
ısıtıldığında parlıyor Eyvallah hava
fişekler patladığında böyle bir sürü
Işıklar saçıyor e fosfor karanlıkta
parlıyor E bunun sebebi nedir diye
düşünmeye başlıyor ve işte çeşitli
çalışmalar yapıyor bu da elektronun
hareketinden kaynaklanıyor diyor yani
atom D diyor Proton ve nötron
gitmeyeceğine göre diyor bu şeye sebep
olan bu ışımaya sebep olanların elektron
olması lazım diyor e diyor bu ışıkların
farklı renkte olmasının sebebi ne diyor
la birisi bakıyorum diyor şey kırmızı
birine bakıyorum Yeşil farklı farklı
renklerde veya biri sarı E bu farklı
rengin Bir sebebi olması lazım diyor ve
oradan işte diyor ki bu demek ki
elektronlar belirli enerji seviyelerinde
olmalı ki o enerji seviyesine göre o
rengi ortaya çıkıyor biliyorsun Her
ışığın kendine özgü bir enerjisi vardır
Kırmızının enerjisiyle mavinin enerjisi
bir değildir İşte bu enerji seviyesi
kavramını buradan ortaya çıkarıyor işte
ne yapıyor ısıtılıp Aleve tutulan
metallerin işte veya çözeltilerin farklı
renkte ış Işıklar saçtığını fark ediyor
Bunun sebebinin işte elektron kavramı
olduğunu söylüyor bak şimdi burada
Baryum stronsiyum lityum sodyum bakır ve
potasyumun renklerini gösteriyor bak
Alev renklerini gösteriyor Aleve
tuttuğunda bu renkler ortaya çıkıyormuş
Bunun sebebini açıklayacak ama ben de
yapmak istiyorum Ha gaza geldim ben de
yapacağım Aha dur ekranı hop büyüttüm
şöyle şunu açıyorum bak benim elimde şey
var burada bakır çözeltisi var bir de
Şurada da lan sen git dur lan gaz
kaçıyor dur Aha yaktım Burada da lityum
çözeltisi var Bak şimdi Işığı kapatıyor
kapatmayın Ya dur şöyle yapacağım bak
şimdi gördün mü rengi bu ne lityum işte
lityumun rengi bu bakırda ne olacak
acaba Bir de bakıra bakalım lan Çok
gürültü yapıyormuş ha bak bakırdag renge
bak görüyorsun değil mi yeşili gördün mü
Aha bak ilk başta bir yeşil çıktı Dur
bir daha yapacağım bir daha yapacağım
dur Heh işte bu ortalığı yakmayalım L
işte bunun sebebinin ne olduğunu
söylüyor elektronlar olduğunu söylüyor
Peki daha ilginç bir şey göstereyim o
fosforla alakalı bir şey göstereceğim
onun için de şöyle yapıyorum dur hop tak
gitti şimdi şu ultraviyole Işık sana
tutmayayım şu benim elimde bir fosfor
var Bak şöyle fosfora tutuyorum fosfora
bir süre tuttuğumda şöyle da sallayarak
tutayım He iyice sonra ışığı kaldırdım
Bak gördün mü ne yaptı parlamaya başladı
işte bunun sebebi de yine elektronun
hareketidir diyor şöyle ışığımızı
yakalım tekrar yine masayı dağıttım ama
Allah'tan bu sefer eşim evde değil Hadi
devam edelim Evet bakalım Diyor ki
yüksek sıcaklığa kadar Isıtılan
maddelerin yaydığı bu ışınlar prizmadan
geçirildiğinde farklı böyle renkler
oluşuyor birazdan söyleyeceğim Onu İşte
buna Spektrum çizgileri diyor Işık
spektrumu ifadesi kullanıyorlar mesela
bunu yapmışsındır prizmadan veya evde CD
ile de yapabilirsin CD'yi böyle Işık
değdiğinde ne oluyor renkler oluşuyor
değil mi Çünkü güneş ışığı geliyor
oradan yansıyınca kırılıyor kırılmaya
uğrayınca da bu renkler ortaya çıkmış
oluyor E bunu söylüyor işte bana ee Bak
ne diyor burada beyaz ışığı gönderdim
bak Farklı renkler ortaya çıktı ama
diğer elementleri gaz haline getirip
bunlarla lamba yapıyorlar bu Lambayı
yani yüksek deminki yaptığım olay var ya
işte ışığı bir veriyor Daha doğrusu
enerjiyi bir veriyor Işık saçmaya
başlıyor bu ışığı da prizmadan
geçirdiğinde bak potasyumda bu renkler
oluşuyormuş şöyle B hatta yaklaştırın
bak şöyle Yaklaştır kalım kalsiyumda bu
renkler oluşuyormuş ne bu skandiyum bu
renkler titanyumda böyle renkler
oluşuyormuş kükürtte Bunlar oluşuyormuş
argona Bakay Maşallah bu renkler
oluşuyormuş işte bak barkod numarası
gibi görüyor musun dıt okuttun mu ne
yapıyor işte diyor ki bu Argon ne bu
renk çizgileri işte her elementin
kendine öz özgüdür diyor ha ne diyor bak
Yukarıdaki gibi her elementin farklı
Işık spektrumları bulunmaktadır diyor
yani prizmadan geçirildiğinde farklı
böyle renk çizgileri meydana getirirler
diyor e nspor her maddenin Işık
spektrumu birbirinden neden farklıdır
diyerek çalışma yapmaya başlıyor işte
enerji seviyelerini de böyle keşfediyor
hidrojen atomu ile yaptığında
çalışmaları bir bakıyor işte Farklı
renkler ortaya çıkıyor bu renklerin
enerjilerini tespit ediyor O zaman diyor
ki ya hidrojende diyor Alt üstü bir tane
elektron var diyor bu elektron Demek ki
diyor farklı farklı yerlere geçer diyor
farklı böyle enerji seviyelerine geçerek
o sırada dışarıya Işık saçmaya başlıyor
demin o
fosfordan üst enerji seviyesine uyarıldı
sonra enerji vermeyi bir kestim tekrar
Eski yerine dönerken o Işık saçmaya
başladı sebebi bu işte dostum burada da
onu söylüyor ve işte ondan sonra da bu
enerji seviyeli model yani yörünge
modelini Ortaya koymuş olduk işte Bor
atom modelindeki Bu enerji seviyeleri Bu
bu daha düşük enerjili dıştaki daha
yüksek enerjili Onun dışındaki daha yü
yüksek Yani dışarıya doğru gittikçe
yüksek yörüngelerde enerji daha fazladır
ifadesini kullanıyor burada da söylüyor
işte elektronlar Çekirdekten belirli
uzaklıkta ve belirli enerjiye sahip
yörüngelerde Dolanır diyor bu
yörüngelere işte enerji düzeyi katman
yörünge ya da kabuk ifadesini kullanıyor
ve şunu söylüyor Hani 1ci katman 2ci
katman 3 4 5 6 7 katman var zaten Şöyle
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 katman var bunlara K
kabuğu L kabuğu M kabuğu n başka klm n o
r diyor işte bazen bu şekilde de
söylenebilir dostum ve ne diyor Bak
burada da söylüyor en uzaktaki enerji
seviyesi maksimum değere sahiptir Eğer
Onun da üzerine çıkacaksa zaten elektron
çıt diye kopup gidiyor diyor çok enerji
aldığımda kopuyor işte ve elektronun
yani atomdaki elektronun en düşük
enerjili olma durumuna Biz temel hal
diyoruz yani enerjisi en düşük hal Tamam
ben burada İyiyim diyor yerim rahat O
işte temel halde Ama sen ona dışarıdan
enerji verirsen demin benim yaptığım
gibi işte ultraviyole ışıkla ne yaptın
fosfora enerji verdim ne yaptım
elektronların rahatını bozdum onları üst
enerji seviyesine uyardım sonra uyardım
ya enerjiyi bir kestim dedi ki ya ben
normal halime döneceğim arkadaş dedi
eski Halime dönmek istiyorum dedi tekrar
eski yörüngeye geçerken de o iki yörünge
arasındaki enerji farkını dışarıya
vermeye başladı O yüzden o yeşilimsi
rengi görmeye başladık Tamam mı dostum
burada da onu söylüyor işte elektron
dışarıdan alan enerji alarak yüksek
enerjili yörüngeye geçerse Buna uyarılma
diyoruz atom uyarılmış halde kararsızdır
yani enerjiyi kestiğimiz anda tekrar
Eski yerine dönme eğilimindedir fosforlu
saatlerde bu şekilde yapılmıştır İşte o
yayılan ışığın enerjisi diyor iki katman
arasındaki enerji farkına eşittir yüksek
enerjiyle eksi düşük enerjiyle aradaki
farkı dışarıya vermiş oluyor o zaman ne
diyoruz elektron düşük enerji
seviyesinden yüksek enerji seviyesine
geçerken dışarıdan enerji alır enerjiyi
ne yaptı bünyesine aldı soğurduğu
Ken de dışarıya yaydı ne yaptı enerjiyi
yaydı ışıma yaptı ışıma spektrumu
Soğurma spektrumu ifadesini kullanıyoruz
başka var mı Heh burada işte burada da
gösteriyor katmanlar var işte bak
katmanlar enerji seviyesi diğer ifadeyle
1ci katman ikinci katman 3üncü katman K
LM katmanları şeklinde çekirdek var
Proton ve nötron Burada elektronlar da
buralarda dolanıyor bak zaten
söylediğimi Burada da tekrar yazmışım
Bir maddenin ısı enerjisini almasına ya
da işte Işık enerjisini almasına absorbe
etmesine absorpsiyon soğur e aldığı
enerjinin bir kısmını ışıma olarak
dışarıya vermesine ise yayılma ışıma ya
da emisyon ifadesini kullanıyoruz Hatta
belki duymuşsundur Evde falan Bu araba
muayenesine giderler araç muayenesine
şey derler egzoz emisyonunu yaptırdın mı
Bak emisyon yani egzozdan çıkan gaz
dışarıya verdiği gaz bunun işte çok
olmaması lazım ya bunu söylüyor
karbondioksit emisyonu önemlidir emisyon
dışarıya yayma anlamında tamam mı dostum
Peki Bor atom modeli her şeyle doğru
muydu değildi ne vardı Bor atom modeli
hidrojen gibi helyum + 1 gibi lityum + 2
gibi ki bak şöyle göstereyim bu nötr
haldeyse bunun elektron sayısı 1 helyum
+ 1 e bir ne bu proton sayısı 2 o zaman
burası 1 Olmalı 1 1 daha 2'yi verecek ya
E bu ne 3'tü Burası 2 ise o zaman bunun
elektron sayısı 1 bak yani ne yapıyor
Bor tek elektronlu tanecikler için çok
güzel açıklama yapıyor ama çok
elektronlu da birazcık batırıyor çok
elektronlarda açıklayamadığı için zaten
bu model ne oluyor eksik kalmış oluyor
sonra ne var elektronun yeriyle alakalı
durum var elektron işte dairesel
yörüngelerde Dolanır diyor değil mi İşte
elektronun yeri tam olarak belirlenemez
Heisenberg bununla beraber çalışma yapan
birisidir Heisenberg Hatta Bor atom
modeli ile ilgili çalışmalar yaparken
buradaki şeyi keşfediyor işte durumu
keşfediyor elektronun hızı yeri tam
olarak belirlenemez diyor elektronun tam
olarak yeri belirlenemediği için
Sonradan da işte elektronun bulunma
ihtimalinin yüksek olduğu yer diye ifade
ediliyor ona da Orbital diyoruz işte Bu
modelde elektronlar belirli yörüngelerde
hareket eder diyoruz ama Heisenberg
Belirsizlik ilkesine göre elektronun
yeri ve hızı aynı anda kesin olarak
belirlenemez diye ifade kullanıyor E o
zaman ne diyoruz elektronların dalga ve
tanecik özelliğinden dolayı yeri tam
olarak belirlenemez Orbital kavramı diye
ifade ediyoruz işte bu sayede de modern
atom modeli yani kuantum atom modeli
ortaya çıkmış oluyor Bununla ilgili
çalışma yapan bir sürü bilim insanı var
Bu ne yapıyorlar işte diyor ki Bor
modelindeki eksiklikleri ortaya
çıkarıyor bilim insanları kuantum modeli
diyorlar buna modern atom teorisi ya da
Bu modelde işte ne yapıyor borun ön
erdiği yörünge yerine ne yapıyorlar
elektronun bulunma olasılığının yüksek
olduğu yerden bahsediyorlar
Heisenberg'in Belirsizlik İlkesi
üzerinden irwin schrodinger sağ olsun bu
Orbital ya da elektron bulutu ifadesi
elektron buralarda bir yerde ama tam
olarak bilmiyoruz yerini şeklinde bir
şey söyleniyor Ya tabii ki böyle muallak
değil ha buralarda bir yerde değil
onlara bir şekiller çıkıyor Üç boyutlu
hepsinden bahsedeceğiz Hadi Bununla
ilgili birazcık soru çözelim diyor ki
Bor atom modeline göre Yukarıdaki
ifadelerden hangileri doğrudur diyor Hım
bakalım bakalım elektronlar belirli
enerjiye sahip yörüngelerde bulunurlar
Evet bu ifadeyi söylüyordu elektronların
enerji seviyelerinde olduğunu söylüyordu
enerji katmanları içten dışa doğru 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 ya da klmn Opr şeklindedir doğru
elektronlar en düşük enerjili olma
durumunda bulunuyorsa temel haldedir
Evet bunu da söylemişti cevap Ne oldu
hepsi oldu burada ne demiş bakalım Bor
atom modelinde Yukarıdaki taneciklerden
hangilerinin davranışı
açıklanabilir diyor Hım Bor atom
modelinde hangilerinin davranışı
açıklamış ZD bakalım temel halde m
katmanında 3 elektron bulunduran atom
bir dakika Bor atom modeli tek
elektronları açıklayabilir 3 elektron
varsa bunu açıklayamaz + 2 yüklü
iyonunda bir tane elektron bulunduran
iyon Bak bir tane elektron bulunduruyor
ola tek elektronlu taneciklerde açıklama
yapabiliyordu O yüzden bunu açıklamıştır
diyor ki nötr hidrojen atomu ya
hidrojenin ne proton sayısı 1 değil mi E
nötr halde elektron sayısı da 1 yani
elektron sayısı 1 olan tanecik olduğu
için bunu da açıklayamaz mı
açıklayabilir o yüzden cevap 2 ve 3 olac
olacaktır yani neymiş D seçeneği mii bu
sorumuza bakalım Diyor ki Bor atom
modelinin kendinden önceki ve sonraki
atom modellerinden farklı olarak ortaya
koyduğu kavram diyor hepsinden farklı
olarak ortaya koyduğu kavram bu yörünge
kavramıyla ifade ediyor elektronların
çizgisel dairesel yörüngelerinden
bahsediyordu Var mı öyle bir ifade Evet
elektronun izlediği varsayılan çizgisel
dairelerden bahsediyordu Evet bunu
söylüyordu ne diyor atomun merkezin de
yer alan pozitif yüklü kısım Ya bunu
Rutherford söylemişti atom
çekirdeğindeki yüksüz tanecik yüksüz
taneciği de Rutherford demişti ama tam
olarak açıklayan ched wikti Yani bunun
bor'la alakası yoktu diyor ki elektronun
bulunma ihtimalinin yüksek olduğu bölge
sonradan bordan sonra keşfediliyor bu
değildi başka ne var nötr atomlarda
proton sayısı elektron sayısına eşitti
yani negatif yüklü taneciğe bunu Thomson
tarafından söylenmişti bunun tarafından
söylenmemiştir o yüzden cevap C
seçeneğidir Bak ne diyor Yukarıdaki
olaylardan hangileri emisyon olayına
yani Işık yayma değil mi yayılma olayına
örnektir diyor kor halindeki demirin
Işık yayması Evet fosforlu maddenin
karanlıkta parıldamaz yayma değil mi
Evet lambanın elektrik altın açıldığında
Işık vermesi Lambalarda ne vardı Böyle
şeyler vardı ortasında hat da şöyle
göstereyim Bir tane şöyle bir Heh ampul
çizelim şöyle ışığı verdiğimde burada ne
olacak elektrik geçtiği için ışıma
gerçekleşecek dışarıya Işık yaydığı için
ne olacak bu da olacak cevabımız E
seçeneğidir şimdi bu ders gördü
gördüklerimizi toparlarsak Nelerden
bahsettik atom modellerinden bahsettik
atom modellerinin peşine Dedik ki işte
Proton nötron elektron bunların atomun
neresinde olduğundan bahsettik Bor atom
modelini detayl adık sonra da bir
Orbital kavramı ortaya çıktı peki bu
Yörünge ve orbitalin farkı ne bunlardan
bahsedelim istersen son olarak da diyor
ki Yörünge ve Orbital kavramı yörünge
dediğimizde aklımıza ne gelecek
elektronun izlediği varsayılan çizgisel
dairesel yoldur diyordu değil mi Kim
söylüyordu bunu işte Bor söylüyordu
Tamam bu yörü kavramında bu elektronun
çizgisel hareketini temsil etmekte
elektron böyle Tamam hareket ediyor
böyle dönüyor gibi ifade ediyor dairesel
şekle sahiptir diyordu E başka atomdaki
enerji düzeylerini temsil eder küçüğün
daha düşük enerji biraz daha büyüdüğünde
daha yüksek enerji daha da büyünde daha
yüksek enerji Bunu ifade ediyor
yörüngeler Yani en düşük enerjili daha
yüksek daha yüksek şeklinde
söyleyebiliriz yörüngelerin kapasiteleri
belirli olduğundan her yörüngede ancak
belirli sayıda elektron bulunabilir Bunu
da daha sonradan söyleyeceğiz yani 2n
kare diye bir formül vardır bir
katmandaki elektron sayısı şeklinde bunu
da işte belirli kapasitede elektron
alabilirler şeklinde söylüyor yörünge
kavramında Peki Orbital kavramı ne Aha
bu şekiller işte Orbital kavramında her
orbitalin kendine özgü bir şekli vardır
s orbitalinin p orbitalinin d
orbitalinin f orbitalinin kendine özgü
şekilleri vardır ve bu şekiller
üzerinden de aslında bu ne demek biliyor
musun elektron buralarda bir yerde işte
bak elektron şuralarda bir yerde
elektron buralarda bir yerde iki
elektron alıyor onu da sö söyleyeceğim
Zaten burada elektronun bulunma
ihtimalinin yüksek olduğu bölgelerdir
diyoruz üç boyutlu bir hareketi temsil
eder çizgisel değildir farklı şekilleri
vardır ve farklı enerji düzeyinde farklı
orbitaller bulunur ki Daha sonra
söyleyeceğiz bunu s p d f orbitalleri
diye ve bir Orbital en fazla 2 elektron
alabilir s' den bir tane olduğu için
bunu daha sonra söyleyeceğim tekrar
söyleyeceğim bunu s' den bir tane olduğu
için 2 elektron alıyor p' den 3 tane
olduğu için 6 elektron alabiliyor D'den
5 tane olduğu için 10 elektron
alabiliyor f'den 7 tane olduğu için 14
elektron alabiliyor bunları daha sonra
detayl acağı zaten Hadi gel şu etkinliği
yapalım sonra da dersi bitirelim
yorulduk çünkü değil mi Bak ne diyor
burada bana burada He görünür ışığın
elektromanyetik spektrumu diyor burada
bilmen gereken şey var O da şu burada
enerji düşüktür burada enerji yüksektir
Hatta şöyle bir şey vardır kutu
sayamam diye bir şey vardır Bu enerjinin
artış sırasıdır kırmızı turuncu sarı
yeşil mavi mor Mora doğru enerji
artmaktadır onu söylemiş olayım burada
da bakalım şimdi bazı şeyler vermiş
diyor ki bana bir atom modeli verilmiş
diyor ki atomun katmanların arasında
elektron geçişleri katmanlar arasındaki
enerji farkına eşittir diyor yani onu
ortaya çıkarırlar diyor ışımayı öyle
yaparlar yukarıda görünür ışığın
elektromanyetik spektrumu ve temel
yapısını gösteren bir şema verilmiş
Atomun temel yapısını göstermiş buna
işte burada renkleri vermiş diyor ki
Buna göre Aşağıda verilen katmanlar
arası elektron geçişine karşı
gelebilecek olası renkleri karşılığına
belirtin demiş şimdi şimdi bak ne
demiştik her yörüngenin belli bir
enerjisi vardı yinin enerjisi birinciden
çok çok fazladır en büyük enerji 7 Hatta
şöyle yazalım buraya şöyle He enerji en
büyük 7'de sonra 6 5 4 3 2 1 şeklinde
gidiyor sığdı mı sığdı çok güzel Şimdi o
zaman ne kadar fazla yörünge arasında
geçiş olursa o kadar fazla enerji açığa
çıkacaktır bak 7'den 2'ye 5 yörünge
geçişi var 5 yörünge geçmiş çok güzel
yazdık yanına şu ne 7'den 3'e 4 yörünge
geçiş var burada 5'ten 3'e 2 yörünge
geçişi var burada 6'dan 3'e 3 yörünge
geçişi var 3'ten 2'ye bir yörünge geçişi
var şimdi 7'den 2'ye çok yüksek
enerjilenme elektron geçiyorsa bu
aradaki fark kadar enerjiyi dışarıya
verecek yani bunların enerjisini
karşılaştırırsak şöyle yazacağım en
yüksek enerji bunda olacak Sonra devam
ediyorum sonraki bunda olacak sonra
bakıyoruz şunda olacak sonraki kimde
Olacak şurada olacak Şuraya da kaç
yazayım 4 numara Şurada zaten bir katman
geçiş var Bu da en düşük olacak böyle he
yüksek enerjili olduğunda renk ne
oluyordu mor oluyordu değil mi He hemen
moru yazdık yani olası şeylerden
bahsediyoruz bu olmak zorunda değil mor
buraya moru yazdık E bu ikinci buydu
sonra maviyi yazalım buraya mavi sonra
ne vardı üçüncüde bakalım sıralamaya
bakarsak enerji sıralamasına Kut He
yeşil Olabilir değil mi yeşil var mı var
Tamam şuraya yeşil yazalım Sonra sonra
sonra 4 numara geliyor 4 numara neler
var elimizde sarı ve kırmızı kaldı değil
mi o zaman şuraya sarıyı en düşük
enerjili kırmızıyı da buraya yazmış
olduk Dostum Evet güzel bir ders oldu
bence bak deney de yapmış oldum burada
Aslında birazcık sözel bir kısımda
dikkatini çektiyse atom modellerinden
bahsettik neler var neler yok onları
detayl adık bunun üzerinden felsefi
yaklaşım nedir işte bilimsel yaklaşım
nedir bundan kısaca bahsetmiş olduk
Sonra da Orbital kavramı ve yörünge
kavramından bahsettik basit bir şekilde
açıklama yaptık bir sonraki dersimde de
neyden bahsedeceğim bu orbitallerden
bahsedeceğim elektron dizilimler inden
bahsedeceğim orası çok önemlidir sakın
kaçırma orayı dostum bir de bununla
ilgili sorular da çözeceğim dostum Paraf
Yayınları sağ olsun IQ 9 sınıf soru
bankası yapmış çok güzel sorular var
gerçekten bayıldım sorulara Onların bir
kısmını çözeceğim size yani tamamını
çözmeyecek Çünkü kitabın tamamını çözmek
bayağı bir vakit alır şöyle yapacağım
ben kitaptaki belli testleri size
çözeceğim beğendiğim testleri çözeceğim
tavsiyem al Gerçekten iyi hazırlanmış
Yani şu anda kitap arıyorsa Eğer IQ 9
sınıf soru bankası çok güzel hazırlanmış
ben oradan sorular çözem etkinlikler var
Yazılı hazırlıklar var yani her şeyi
düşünmüşler ki Zaten oradaki
etkinlikleri de yazılı hazırlıkları da
size zaten yazılıya hazırlık çalışması
olarak yapacağım ekstra çalışmalarım da
olacak tabii ki oradaki soruları da
çözeceğim eğer o kitabı alıp oradan
takip edersen güzel olur diye
düşünüyorum ama diyelim ya hocam Yok ben
alamıyorum öyle bir durumum yok tamam
şöyle yapacağım işte ben soru çözeceğim
ya onların pdf'i paylaşamıyorum Tabii ki
yani sonuçta Eee Emek verilmiş edilmiş
Tamam bunları konu anlatımı olduğu için
paylaşabiliyorum ama onları
paylaşamayan Durdur O sırada ekrandaki
soruları çözmeye çalış sonra devam et
benimle beraber o şekilde yani ekrandan
soru çözerek de gidebilirsin dostum o
zaman dinlenmeyi hak ettik iki fosfor
bir asit kimya Bu kadar basit bir
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere hoşça kal